- "C'est une invitation inédite
et un honneur", a dit
Simon Jolin-Barrette.
SIMON JOLIN-BARRETTE, min. resp.
de la Langue française, Québec
- C'est la première fois
qu'un ministre étranger,
dans l'histoire de l'Académie
française, est invité
à prononcer un discours.
- Le ministre de la Langue
française n'a d'ailleurs pas su
cacher son émotion en évoquant
ses ancêtres et les liens
qui unissent les destins
québécois et français.
- Dans ce temple de la langue
française, dans ce lieu de
mémoire, c'est un descendant de
Georgelin, un modeste meunier,
qui se tient devant vous.
(raclement de gorge)
- S'il a longuement parlé
du passé, c'est de l'avenir
dont il était question.
- C'est inspiré par toute la
fougue du peuple québécois que
je prends la parole en ces murs.
(raclement de gorge)
Le Québec vous tend la main.
Il vous convie à une union des
forces entre nos deux nations,
basée sur la certitude que le
français n'est pas une cause du
passé, mais un fervent d'avenir,
un moteur de résistance
et de renaissance.
- Pendant près d'une heure,
Simon Jolin-Barrette a entretenu
les académiciens et leurs
invités de la Loi sur la langue
officielle et commune du Québec,
la loi 96. Son auditoire était
déjà plutôt conquis, mais
il a tenu à défendre la loi.
- Nous sommes les voisins
d'une grande puissance,
les États-Unis, et nous évoluons
à l'intérieur d'une fédération
à majorité anglophone.
- "Et donc, a dit le ministre,
le français accuse un recul
important, inquiétant."
- Nous aurions tort de voir
dans le mouvement massif vers
l'anglais un phénomène anodin.
On nous le présente comme
une ouverture sur le monde
en balayant du revers de la main
toutes les objections.
- Simon Jolin-Barrette a déploré
les critiques, qu'il juge
diffamatoires, de la loi 96,
dans une certaine presse
anglophone canadienne
et américaine. Une presse
complaisante, a-t-il dit.
- Des auteurs peu rigoureux
y dépeignent notre combat
sous l'angle le plus dénigrant
et le plus insultant, en tenant
de le faire passer pour
un combat d'arrière-garde,
une forme d'autoritarisme.
Notre combat pour la langue
française est juste.
C'est un combat universel,
celui d'une nation qui a résisté
pacifiquement à la volonté
de puissance des plus forts.
- Les Français qui s'intéressent
à la question linguistique
savent l'opposition que suscite
la loi 96, mais ils se
l'expliquent mal. Au contraire,
disent-ils, elle devrait servir
d'inspiration pour la France, ùu
le français est aussi en danger.
HÉLÈNE CARRÈRE-D'ENCAUSSE,
secrétaire perp. Académie fran.
- Elle est en danger
et par notre propre faute,
par notre négligence.
Et, je dois dire, vous êtes
beaucoup plus attentifs à la
langue française que nous. Par
conséquent, nous vous regardons.
- À l'évidence, les anglicismes
dans l'espace et la parole
publics ont la cote en France.
Plutôt que d'inquiéter, ils
confèrent une image branchée.
Mais le problème va plus loin,
croit ce linguiste.
BERNARD CERQUIGLINI,
linguiste français
- C'est vrai qu'on parle
français depuis toujours,
en France. L'État parle
français. Et donc,
on a l'impression qu'on
est tranquilles. Mais non!
Mais non, mais non!
Dans certains domaines...
Il s'agit pas seulement
d'anglicismes! Dans certains
domaines, on abandonne la
langue. Ce qui m'inquiète,
c'est l'abandon de la langue,
plus que son métissage.
- Autrement dit, à l'heure
de la mondialisation et de ce
que le ministre Jolin-Barrette a
qualifié de "rouleau compresseur
des GAFAM", tous les
francophones sont des Gaulois
qui doivent résister.
Ici Marie-Eve Bédard,
Radio-Canada, Paris